Hows it going bros
my name is PewDiePie
Do I really have to say that every fucking time
no im just kidding
The Impossible Quiz
It's a game that you bros have suggested
about 5 fucking Million times
The fact that the game is called the impossible quiz
has been a reason for me not
wanting to play it
Look at that, I was tired of my intro back in 2013
LOOK WHO'S BACK EVERYBODY
The Impossible Quiz
The original Impossible quiz came out 10 Years ago this year. We'll all be dead soon.
Cant wait to play this one!
yes
Slap-Me-Do
Oh how I missed you
10 Years anniversary
Impossible Quizmas, we are back
Back
Of course I'm going to beat this game.
And its gonna be easy
Why? because I'm the greatest gamer on the planet
everyone knows this
everyone
ask anyone on the street
ask your mom
'Whos the best gamer?' oh its PewDiePie
first question
you can play along of course.
first question, on the first day of impossible quizmas my true love gave to me...
Hepatitis B
*claps* DAMN I'M GOOD AT THIS GAME
Who draped spaghetti over scrooges chest?
The ghost of Christmas pasta
The ghost of Christmas present
The ghost of Christmas yet to come
*chuckles* WHAT?!
okay, the pasta, It was the pasta
"What is this?"
it's waving salt
seasons greetings
pepper people
an abomination.
Seasons greetings
This is easy
oh shit, Find the dodgy bulb
uhh, I found it
This is so easy
are you kidding me?
are you kidding me right now
I'm killing it, Im gonna beat this game on the first try
just watch me
"What makes Rudolph's nose glow red?"
Fairy dust
Santa's bum crumbs
Elf dandruff
Years of alcohol abuse
Just pick the most horrific answer
and you get it right every time
hey, you want some? huh, you want that
ahh
ah
erhh
What am I doing here
Jesus christ, OOHHH
Merry Christmas everybody
ho ho ho
How do I dab?
I think that's the reason
thats what i gotta do right?
What do I gotta do?
Oh I just had to keep making him licking it
I knew that! shut up
"Who wrote the song silent night?"
Franz Xaver Gruber
Carol
Joseph Mohr
A rather Intelligent orang utang
Dammit
Joseph Mohr
Oh look at that I actually
I actually game over Give Up
Wait this is a new question
Aw don't randomize it
"What is this?"
Oh that's a great question
I'm Bored
The true meaning of
Sweet OH its sweet baby jesus
There, I found it.
Okay.
What makes Rudolph's Nose,
It was uh
Years of alcohol abuse
and then you gotta lick it
I don't know why that wasn't obvious to me
Jebus
Okay "Who Wrote the song 'The Twelve Days Of Christmas?"
uuh
Someone from france
God Dammit
I hope its not a hundred questions like last time
Jesus
Okay on the f-
*Belch*
U-Okay
Alright, Okay, Alright where are you
Where are you
There you are
You little Bichh
"What makes Rudolph's Nose?" Years of alcohol abuse.
Lick it
Lick it you little Bitch
2013 PewDiePie is back baby
Carol wrote that
Ew
EW
Why the hell did you make this game in flash?
I forgot
It was this one wasn't it
Yes
Frank says
G
I
B
GIBL
Giblets
Guy
Oh Great
Nice one, Thank you
"Where does Father Christmas leave your presents?"
Uhhh
On the roof
In a bear trap
Are you kidding me
I got them all wrong
Come on
Oh God I gotta do all this?
Sweet Baby Jesus
Man i'm really feeling the holiday spirit
Right about now
Okay what do you want
G
I
Giblet
Alright, here we go
In your stockings
What?
On the roof
I don't know then.
"So now there's a Christmas quiz, how about a Halloween Special?"
2 Spoopy
DAMMIT
STOP
S Prrrr Ooooo,
Sprouts
Okay
This is a tricky one
I have to click somewhere else right?
It's a fake one
Alright whatever
"so now there's a Christmas quiz how about"
Uh
Too Late!
I cant be arsed?
wait what the hell is it then?
Advent calendar chocolate
Death Ball
Tinsel
Great, thank you
Oh my god
Im already sick of this
I don't know!
There's a tricky one
It's a snake one
But I clicked them all
I clicked on "Too Late!"
I clicked "Too Spoopy"
I clicked I cant be ar-
I clicked that one
Are you kidding me!
"How would you rate this quiz so far?"
Oh yeah I already got it right once
Don't say anything.
Not as good as the originals
I hate you
Okay
It's almost too christmassy
Mediocre
What the hell is the answer!?
Christmas tree
On the roof
In a bear Trap
What the hell
I don't fucking know
In your stockings
Then in your asshole
I don't
Where else am I supposed to click?
So dumb.
Mediocre
Hoaaaaaaa
I don't fucking know what that is.
A Bauble?
Oh my god
Which one blinked
I didn't see
So Dumb
I don't know
I'm gonna sit it out
Fuck me
Okay that didn't work
"How would you rate" 13
Oh my god I had to click the star.
Great
Fantastic
Oh what is this
There's something here
It's hidden underneath all the missiles
Oh
No It's over here actually
Is this it?
That was it
"Where do pirates hide their Christmas presents?"
In a massive chest
In the bowels of the cracken
Pirates don't celebrate christmas
Under a palm tree
ouhh
In the bowels of the cracken
*whispers* fuck
Don't look at me like you knew the answer
'cause you didn't
uhg what did I pick
I picked this one
and I picked  this
no I picked this one
in a massive chest
That's so lame, under a palm tree
Then I don't know
stop asking me
What th-
What the hell
I don't Know
There must be a secret
There is a secret here somewhere
and I shall find it
Did I-
did I hit
Pirates don't celebrate Christmas?
I hate this
Quiz
Why would they do this to me?
I beat the first one
I've gotta do all this again?
"Where do pirates hide their Xmas?"
On the
(Sudden realization)
It's on the X everyone
"Prepare for takeoff!"
What do I do?
I am prepared!
WHAT DO I DO!?
Oh my God
Ohhhh
What do I do here?
What do I
What am I doing here?
Great
you just hid it there
Fantastic
What do I do
I hate the timed ones
its like dude
Fuck of
Alright
Another timed one
Santa
You're not santa
You're not even santa
oh
Oh
Satan
Sataaa- *laughs*
I don't know what I did
is that
Oh okay, wait
Skip, Skip
Okay I've got it
Satan
SA-
TA-
Satan!
SATAN!
"NOËL!"
Valentine's
Halloween
Yuletide
Easter
Yulitde
Yuletide
Dammit
Uhh
Easter
Oh my god
Oh
It's a keyboard
It's a Keyboard
Its the arrows
It was the arrows
GENIUS
I'm Genius!
I'M A GODDAMN EINSTEIN,
I'M A RICK & MORTY 3000
"What's the most popular Christmas Wine?"
Savignon Blanc
You know what
A Pinot Noir
This game is out of culture
I don't know
Slippers
Slappers
Tissues
You can't wear tissues
but what is this then?
Skip
Hey, I got another skip
*laughs*
Oh wow!
No it's
uhhh
AHHHHHHHHH
Did I do it?
I did it
But then I miss-clicked
GOD DAMMIT GAME
"What is a Turlock?"
A Turkish wizzard
*laughs* damn it
God dammit
Somewhere you can stuff a turkey
what does that mean?
Reindeer testes
it must be that
Great
to uh-
God dammit
I don't get it
Wait what?
Oh god i'm dead
Oh I'm dead
aww shit
It's the 25th time to open your presents
if you got any
Okay
What do you mean?
hey!
what?
what did I do?
Okay
Blue
RED
*inhales* it's working
Blue
Yellow!
I'm a genius!
Daaahhhh-
Merry Christmas
Congratulations, You did it!
check out your presents on the collections page
back to menu
WOW
It would seem that the impossible Quizmas
would-
would be renamed
Possible Quizmas
'Cause it was EASY!
Told you!
I told you!
Merry Christmas everybody
Hope you have a great happy holidays
And all that stuff
Credits to me
for beating this game
See you next time everybody, PeacePie